[Musique]
le 2000 à la rade eustache bonjour
bonjour monsieur livory alors vous êtes
candidate à saint pierre vous avez 52
ans vous êtes adjoint administratif à la
ctm vous à vous êtes tous avaient été
première adjointe de raphaël martin à
saint pierre
vous êtes conseiller municipal de
l'opposition
et vous allez conduire la liste rappelez
moi le nom de votre liste agissant pour
saint-pierre agissons posé seins puis à
pourquoi vous présentez alors permettez
tout d'abord que je salue les personnes
qui nous regardent et qui nous écoutent
et ce que je présente aussi tous mes
voeux les meilleurs en 2020 pour tous
les martiniquais mais aussi tous les
pierrotin toutes les familles pied
routine alors pourquoi je me présente
mais je dirais pourquoi pas je suis
pyrrhotine je suis une jeune pied
routine je suis né à saint pierre j' ai
des souvenirs d'enfance à saint pierre
je ma vie est à saint pierre je suis je
travaille à saint pierre je travaille à
saint pierre je suis investi au sein de
cette commune depuis de nombreuses
années puisque politiquement mais aussi
au niveau associatif puisque je suis
j'étais maire-adjoint à la commune de
saint pierre pendant 14 ans la mandature
de raphaël martin justement ce que ce
n'est pas encore un retour de l'équipe
martin qu'on a inversé il y a
[Musique]
lors des dernières élections c'est pas
ça ce que vous représentez pas jeu un
peu
l'équipe martin enfin un génial je vais
pas vous faire un peu le reproche je
pense qu'on s'est souvent à saint pierre
que on voit là ce qu'on disait on disait
voilà il fallait enlever l'équipe martin
est là pourquoi une autre personne de
martin se représente en tout cas j'ai
voté pour vous en tout cas je suis
candidate je suis jeune sean pyrrhotine
je suis une femme de la commune et pour
moi c'est un devoir
la commune a donné maintenant à moi de
le servir de redonner ce que la commune
m'a donné je suis candidate et c'est de
la démocratie un qui va parler
je suis fier de venir servir cette
population comme je disais tout à
l'heure que j'ai servi pendant 14 années
au niveau municipal mais aussi au niveau
des associations j'ai été secrétaire de
la darpa une association de personnes
âgées
j'ai je suis président d'une association
de portage de repas pour les personnes
âgées dans le nom caraïbes et je suis
aussi également président présidente
agissons pour saint pierre
alors tout cela fait que aujourd'hui je
suis j'ai tissé des liens avec la
population
je suis emballé je dirais déterminée à
venir servir une commune qui est chère à
mon coeur et je suis entouré de femmes
et d'hommes qui ont qui ont la même
motivation et la même détermination que
moi on dit souvent qu'on saint pierre ne
bouge pas que le patrimoine liban mise
en valeur à saint pierre vous le
constatez également il y a du travail à
faire
il y a toujours du travail à faire nous
avions quand nous étions élus nous
avions entamé un certain nombre de
choses au niveau du patrimoine
nous avons relancé le label ville d'art
et d'histoire et que nous avions qui à
l'époque quand osorno arrivée aux
affaires
c'était une association qui s'en occupe
et donc nous avons mis fait les choses
au niveau de la municipalité au niveau
de la mairie que nous puissions avoir ce
label et nous avons mis en place tout un
certain nombre de 2,2 d'outils recruter
une animatrice du patrimoine et il reste
tant qu'on y est et restera toujours à
faire
quels sont les thèmes que vous allez
développer pendant cette campagne
exactement alors lui mais elle sera au
coeur de nos préoccupations
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui vous
pensez que qu'on prend pas en compte le
les besoins les les avis des pierrotin
c'est parce que nous nous entendons sur
le terrain que nous faisons nous
rencontres de proximité
nous avons une population qui est très
satisfaite
donc nous avons nous pouvons pas rester
bouche fermée et bras croisés nous avons
le devoir de venir remettre la cohésion
sociale à saint-pierre remettre redonner
aux pieds au teint une ville où il fait
bon vivre où ils sont épanouis et c'est
là toute ma motivation après l'humeur il
ya aussi la partie économique
si la culture est un levier économique
il faudra deux par saint pierre a des
atouts c'est pierrade un potentiel
extraordinaire de par son passé
on devra de par son passé historique et
historiques culturels nous devrions
faire de saint pierre leleux la ville la
capitale culturelle et historique de
dunes aux caraïbes
le nil à la vague de stage je vous
remercie
[Musique]